shall we shall we jump to the next yes
do it horrifying story well I don't know
and it's not I don't even think it's
that horrifying because this is a
significantly lower number than I they
said long ago when this first started
happening
they were like 3.4% it's gonna hit 70%
of everybody that's roughly one to two
million people or something died don't
know but I got bad news for you man they
were saying that if we do nothing okay
we can expect a range of like over
between 1 million and 7 million yeah if
we do nothing if we don't know there's a
distance we're and they're saying now if
we do full-on social distancing and
full-on lockdown mmm 100,000 at 240,000
dead that's significantly lower than
what they were saying in the beginning
that's it's not at all it's due to
different metrics true but I mean it's
if if there's gonna be a choice between
100,000 and 1 million 2 million like who
you can what are you gonna choose then
all you're really saying is we should
lock down yeah I think well I mean the
number of different metrics that the
first number is if we don't lock down
millions die if we do lock down hundreds
of thousands die that's why we're
locking down yeah well right now we are
already locked down right right or or
more so we are we are for the most part
lock down a lot I think like 30 states
31 35 % of Americans I thought are not
locked down they're locked down but
there's a lot of states that haven't
locked down at all so what they're
saying here and this is this was really
annoying because there was a story going
around that this like famous researcher
had changed the numbers that like he was
initially saying millions of died now
he's saying only 20,000 it's not true he
was saying that if we lock down the UK
and can expect 20,000 dead if we don't
it can be half a million for us in the
u.s. they think the rate worst-case
scenario with like a 3.4 a 3% mortality
rate we could be looking at like 7
million dead if we completely lock down
so so here's your the reason the numbers
change our health care system can handle
a certain capacity after it's over
capacity the mortality rate will
skyrocket right right the reason them so
the mortality rate is actually decently
low for the u.s. it's like what would
you say 0.6% or something
to the worlds 3.7 yeah and it's because
we have hospitals for people to go to
but that's also not taking into account
the economy being completely stalled so
like if we're all in our homes the
economy is just slowly stopping to like
the wheels coming to a stop it's like
okay we've successfully like we only
have a hundred thousand that have passed
away because of this let's get back to
work and everyone's like what work you
know there's no jobs right it's not
there and then then it's not the corona
virus that's killing people it's like
lack of food and all writing and all the
red strike bro yeah the red strike is
coming right yep it's like it was like
one of the Google I saw Google search
like the the googling not being able to
pay rent hit oh that's new the lights
just shut off on us
perhaps the assassin is coming to finish
us off because you may kill the lights
are that's still pretty good just with
these two but that is really weird that
that would have happened yeah that is
weird
so for those that are watching how many
with three of the lights hopefully
they're still watching yeah they're
still there look man are you talking
about that that Duncan feller yeah well
they got to cut the lights before they
come and finish us off we're not lying
in bed yet though yeah yeah I made a
joke about it what else you talking
about you move quickly I think it's even
more damning the first subject that we
were talking about cuz they seemed to
wanted to keep that under wraps on my
raps like well why isn't anyone talking
about it I'm still kind of shocked that
more people are not talking about the
fact that China was smuggling in this
virus not necessarily this exact strain
but SARS and MERS both he had both of
them focus later man I think look let's
do this a second strike yeah because
yeah because we can talk about the the
tanking economy and all that stuff but I
think the big issue all right so we've
seen the numbers yeah hundred thousand
two hundred forty thousand are expected
to die with social distancing and
lockdown
that's really really bad but it's better
than the million-plus they like the
low-end estimate with no lockdown was a
million plus debt yeah but also I want
before we move on to the rent strike I
also had that article about how Germany
is testing everybody and their death
rate is actually only like
point-like for people under 40 it's it's
really low like point one yeah six or
something and so so what what we're
learning from that is the mortality
rates probably artificially high because
we don't test everybody exactly and not
we have known and and not everybody gets
like the classic symptoms but here's
that here's the other issue it's
affecting every we don't test everybody
for the flu we missed anybody true it
right if we why would we give the flu a
very low estimate and ignore it and then
give a really high estimate it's the
same metrics if we're if we're looking
at the flu and saying here's what we
think and we're looking at corner of
eyes saying here's what you think we're
using the exact same method to test for
what we think and the corona virus is
worse you see I'm saying I do yeah so
whether or not we decide to lock
everything down and just live in caves
and then grow food in our basements
because we have a Martian you know you
know I don't know inclined to think that
it's it's not as bad as I originally
thought I think it's worse I think it I
think it is really bad I I thought it
was really really bad though before and
now I'm seeing the numbers and it's like
it's unhealthy people that are being hit
by this that are I mean it's not the flu
it is worse than the flu you know so I
thought it was going to be significantly
worse than it is so I'm finding out it's
not as bad as I thought maybe you just
had different perspectives the only the
anecdotal that the stories I've seen
from people it's not the smokers and the
obese people of course those people that
are dying right but I think that could
be because the healthier people are
living mm-hmm so they tell their stories
and their stories are horrifying one one
do did a Twitter thread where he was
like at first I had some coughs it was
not linear like any other illness I've
ever had it's what the guy said he was
like typically I feel like I'm getting
sick it gets really bad and and slowly
gets better he's like with this it was
like I felt kind of sick the next day I
felt fine the next day I was coughing up
blood for two days I coughed up blood a
day later I felt a little bit better the
next day I felt really really really
good and then a day later I was back to
coughing up blood with a fever
struggling and laying in bed so the
stories that I've seen from people who
have made it through this are horrifying
like people dropping dead passing out
meeting collapsing
and I think the people who are likely to
die you know like this we have it the
CDC says straight up CDC says diabetes
lung disease heart disease and smoking
may increase risk of severe coronavirus
illness makes sense and this is from
from you know like an hour ago
and well yeah of course yeah that's true
for anything yeah it makes sense but
what's crazy is the healthy people like
21 year old woman in the UK just dies
okay
I mean was she a smoker do you know no
she was not the point didn't say that I
read the whole are you this store this
the stories I'm specifically referring
to that I brought up are like an athlete
all American lacrosse player with no
underlying symptoms wouldn't being put
in a coma like these stories are scary
game changers yet see what's that my
mind keeps going to this this this
documentary about dude I'm not you know
I don't play that because I've seen so
many documentaries and I know how people
play with information okay so it's like
yeah I've seen I mean I I see what
you're saying but they they have
specific like experiments that they go
through the entire process yeah they do
that that's that's it's it's it's so
it's so easy okay to to isolate and
manipulate information to make people
believe something regardless so that's
why it's really difficult to know what's
true or what isn't well then my whole
thing I was about to say it means
nothing huh
I don't know say what you weren't
accepted said we're gonna say well I
think that it has something to do with
with and the animal protein in your
blood I think it because well I'm gonna
continue saying what I'm gonna say right
doesn't matter anyway so in this game
changers there's like the animal protein
and eating meat and and dairy clogs up
the blood and it doesn't allow oxygen to
flow through your blood at the same and
it makes me I mean really what I'm
getting down to is I want to know how
many of these people that are getting
sick that are supposedly healthy eat a
very heavy meat and dairy diet you know
cuz I know a fun a friend of mine who
had coronavirus and he it's not exactly
heavy into eating meat and he like he's
young he's thirty I think and he you
know he got through it and everything's
fine he's healthy now so that's great
but it's like I want to know how many of
these people that are getting sick are
vegan just it just for my own knowledge
because I I have a feeling there's a
correlation I'm not saying there is
because I don't know but after I've seen
so many doc
I've seen so many and I've done so much
research on it and this this one in
particular sticks out in my head because
of the way that they talk about things
the way that they did at all so have you
done the same research on keto ketogenic
diets no I haven't the people in Serbia
who have no heart disease they have
clean blood and all they do is eat like
the livers of walrus okay they eat
nothing but animal protein no vegetables
at all and they're they're considered to
be healthier and stronger with lower
mortality rates lower infections lower
cancer sure I'm just talking a direct
correlation with the coronavirus like
are they also healthy against the corona
virus and they don't they don't eat
sugars at all right right no sugar sugar
another thing that this kind of stuff
thrives off of well [ __ ] goes bad we
know that yeah so so again that that
could be equally as important to know I
want to know all of those facts also I
agree that'd be great yeah I just I just
don't think you know III throw back to
like you'd see a story this is a true
this is a true thing that happened when
I was when I was a kid on like Sunday
they said new new study reveals that
coffee causes cancer or like people who
drink coffee have a percentage of you
know higher percentage of getting cancer
and then three days later they're alike
a news a new study out of this
University says people who drink coffee
have a lower chance of getting cancer
okay and so it is a common thing if you
talk to these researchers they will tell
you how the media lies and misrepresents
and people can so easily take facts and
the truth and turn it into a lie and
then not have lied it's so it's so easy
to do well all I was doing was trying to
speculate on this exact thing yeah
that's what I was doing my issue is that
you know from where I'm standing on all
of the stuff I've researched in terms of
diet and health there's you could you
can find an equal number of people
talking about the health advantages of
ketogenic diets meat and dairy stay away
you know and leafy greens of course they
say you want stay away from carbs daily
from sugars you want to do heavy fat
diet like keto is like almost entirely
fat okay and they say like oh they swear
up and down then you have nutritionists
who swear that sugar is absolutely
important and you got to consume a lot
of it and you want a low-fat diet with a
lot of glucose it's like dude I've read
so many different you know like treatise
or thesis
different thesis Azure theses feces
there you go unlike different diets and
stuff so for me just kind of like I
don't I don't know if that's an issue
you know I do know that if you're
overweight because you eat a pint of Ben
and Jerry's every day you're probably
gonna die and a lot of people who are
dying like we've even seen it it was it
was one of the project Veritas videos to
where the doctor said they've got health
issues they're overweight they have
diabetes and they're dying well all I
want to know is if it is more
information so if they are vegans I
would like to know just for my own
common knowledge if they are in ketosis
if that's what they're going for
I would like to yeah I want to know like
what what are the correlations between
all the things that's that's all I was
trying to figure out but I'd be willing
to bet but we're not we're not
documenting it that much I'd be willing
about it's it's it's static it's it's
regular American diets so you're gonna
see some people who eat a cheeseburger
every day we're fine some way to
cheeseburger every day we die well you
referenced a UK girl is it the same
thing so the reason I'm highlighting the
young people who are seemingly healthy
or asymptomatic dying is because those
are the anecdotes that are scary yeah
it's what's you know it could be the
media highlighting things we don't
normally hear about since it that's an
issue maybe people die the flu like this
walking pneumonia or whatever yeah
people would be one with the strange
like claps and die of the flu or
something mm-hm but we don't hear those
stories and maybe it's just the media
overhyping things or maybe this is
actually something scary there's a
reason why all these governments are
freaking out across the world so what
we've heard from some of the doctors on
the ground is that it's a new thing it's
freaking people out I think it's that
it's novel that's the big issue it
tracks very similarly to Spanish flu in
1918 and I think that's why everyone's
freaking out about cents but but I don't
know I think the death rates gonna be
high but it already the projections were
wrong we are below the low end estimates
for how many people would have died by
now that's a good thing a lot of people
are saying it's proof that you know they
were wrong and they overhyped things or
it's it's it's proof that we did a good
job and we're holding things down and
we're saving lives
yeah that's great you know I think it's
funny that in New York Cuomo is
stockpiling ventilators some of the
hospitals aren't being you know overrun
meanwhile he's claiming the end is nigh
quick we got to get you know 40
and ventilators and it's like yeah I get
it I get it there are a lot of people
who don't seem to understand that just
because one Hospital is empty you know
that doesn't mean everything's fine
it means like you know the way I explain
it is you can go to McDonald's in
Manhattan and see a line at the door
cross the Williamsburg Bridge and the
McDonald's in Brooklyn is empty so it's
like McDonald's well well right
everyone's like McDonald's is being shut
down we need to bring in more supplies
right but for this one right you know I
mean so hospitals in Brooklyn are not
overloaded but hospitals in Manhattan
are getting you know overloaded but I
don't I don't know what to expect I
don't know what we'll end up seeing what
I do know is that if we do if we do
nothing it'll be really really bad yeah
if we do too much it will also be really
really good thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you